Tyler is with us in Baton Rouge hi Tyler
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hey
Davis Manor talking to you
you too sir how can I help I got in a
situation in April of last year I was
coming up on a layoff at my job in
Pascagoula Mississippi and the railroad
called me up in Baton Rouge and they
offered me a job and I was only making
50,000 a year at the time of the layoffs
and you know God blessed me with this
opportunity over here at the railroad
I had $30,000 worth of debt at the time
limit that within the first four months
would you make of how much you make I
was making uh I was making $50,000 a
year back home at my last June
yeah and and when I got the opportunity
to come to the railroad I make yeah I
made about a hundred thousand oh no
honey Wow yes sir yeah you went from
being laid off to doubling your income
look at you ding ding thank you God okay
thank you guys that's right so my
problem is you know my wife is disabled
so she can't move over here with me so
what I did was I oh you can't be
disabled in Baton Rouge well you know
she needs her mom and dad you know help
her out you know and get around and all
that stuff you know while I'm at work so
that's okay that's kind of this you were
facing what's the nature of your
disability you know it's like a brain
disorder type thing it's like a
neurological thing so she can't drive or
anything or get the kids at school or
anything like that but what I'm getting
at is you know it's uh it's it's really
good to have the support back home so
she couldn't move it with me at the time
so what I ended up doing was a found of
annual Craigslist traits of the llama or
in the case of beer for it and you
treated me yes did you say trade of the
lawnmower in a case of one
or okay a lawnmower and a case of beer
for a van
I got you I love this guy okay so I've
moved into the van because I didn't want
to pay I'm in debt at that point right I
just want to move it I didn't want to
move into an apartment and have a two
mortgages and then also have debts pay
off on top of that so I just basically
been living in my van for the past year
now I'm dead
and down by the river oh you're
incredible man you are really right
you're roughing it in order to get your
family straightened out I'm proud of you
I'm so so I've got about $95,000 left on
the mortgage mm-hmm at the rate of the
money that I'm making right now if I
just kept doing this for like two years
I could have the house paid off you know
by the time I'm 30
mm-hmm so would you recommend me just do
this for like the next two years just
keep doing it I mean I ain't bothering
me too bad and paying off in two years
and then move back home and then take
another job making like 50,000 a year
again or you can just do this like ten
years and you know so what were you
doing when you lived there before I'm an
electrician okay and the railroad
doesn't have jobs they're not really no
sir
okay I kind of like I would look for an
option where I didn't make 50,000 but I
went back home I'd like to make 75,000
and then I'm going back home and getting
out of the van down by the river as soon
as I can if I'm you you know you know
you're willing to do it I mean that's
very manly on your part I appreciate you
you know sacrificing for the good of
your family I'm not sure well I got to
answer the truth the truthful question
I'm not doing that I wouldn't do that
but if you're willing to do it it's not
a bad thing Wow
Wow
[Music]